ernie johnson shaquille o'neal kenny the
jet smith charles barkley matt had a
good day good good peloton ride today
got the wordle in three and then uh
looked around on the internet you see
anything on the internet today that uh
caught your attention yeah i see people
messing with my older brother messing
with his older brother yeah i don't like
that why are you messing with him or
maybe clapping back yeah clapping back
that doesn't bother me at all y'all know
better yeah no i don't think it should
bother you i don't think it should
bother him and it shouldn't bother oh it
bothers him he you know he's sensitive
cindy that's this whole uh
this driver bus rider thing what you got
jeremy oh let me see what it is
easy money sniper that'd be kd yeah
he put a picture of me and three old
guys on there i got no problem with that
yeah
everybody had a couple though yeah had
this one uh where would chuck be without
the big homies well we didn't win
anything together that uh when i was a
bus driver i didn't win anything just
like him who was the bus driver on that
bunch well uh nobody there we were all i
was a rookie and they were all past
their prime
there you go
hey listen i can i don't i don't i
didn't see that one what we about to do
is go back back at the time
you know you know i think
uh for me as yeah we this is you see
what rob perez
va observer tweeted out no let's take a
look at that too
yeah he said
it's okay to defend yourself but the
mistake kd made was doing this in the
morning and giving inside time to
prepare they have an army of producers
experienced
they're going to be in photoshop all day
those stage directors probably setting
up for a band no and i didn't even
remember katie says an army of producers
against the god just another tuesday you
meet a god who's sitting home with a
play-in banner um
you think they put that playing banner
up already listen i could put i could
put up stuff about him and russell and
james and and uh serge ibaka would make
sense and i'm just saying i said wait a
minute if somebody said i see him and i
ain't gonna respond i says you want me
to put up him russ uh james and uh serge
ibaka i said no listen k.d is a great
player only point i was making life is
different when you leave the driving the
bus you can see what we're doing
so let's leave it well i i don't want to
leave this one i have one point to it
just one you've been making is it gone
no it's different it's different
when the bus driver for me i think
you're okay
you're not in this company
what i'm saying yes i am no you're not
cause i'm good no you're not listening
how do you know what i'm gonna say that
because my point is
when you say it bus driver
to me it disrespects you it's not
disrespectful
you couldn't finish what you have
accomplished because then it gives the
ignorant people go oh he didn't win a
championship he's not great you say it
every week no i said you didn't win a
champion i didn't i never said you
wearing great i didn't know and i didn't
know and i never said this
oh you said he was a great group
and i never said you weren't a champion
but there's a difference between winning
a championship and being a champion
so wait just in my break i think that
you are our champion but it goes so many
other things and variables to win a
championship so to say bus rival the
average person that's what i'm saying
the person who doesn't know basketball
they're not in the conversation they're
in the conversation
we're not paying the internet any
attention
but then why would we show the internet
if we're not showing anything
no but everyone is talking about but
they're unfolding they're uninformed so
then they're going oh well you got to be
driving the bus no they don't get it but
guess what everyone don't have a say-so
we got g14 classification no man bus
driver means it's your team the the poor
worth
when i'm in the room with the other hall
of famers i don't get to sit at their
table that's the way it is lebron has
said he had to wait to see that they too
because they they're champions you're a
champion no no no that's my point to me
kenny that doesn't make sense well to me
it doesn't well that's why you're not in
the conversation okay okay then you
ain't a champion saying you're not a
champion we haven't won a championship
yes we have a playoff series to talk
about can we move can we move on let's
go carm